اقتحام اسرائيليون جديد لمخيم جنين
للاجئين اسفر عن مقتل شاب في 19 من عمره
واصابه العشرات بجروح الاقتحام استهدف هذه
المره حي الهدف غرب المخيم في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله وندلعت مواجهه في المكان
بين الشبان الفلسطينيين والقوات
الاسرائيليه التي اطلقت بدورها الاعيره
الناريه وقنابل الغاز باتجاههم مصادر
فلسطينيه قالت ان قوات خاصه اسرائيليه
العسكريه بهدف اعتقال الشاب راتب الباليه
فاطلقه على منزله
ونشرت قناصه على اسطح المنازل المجاوره
واستهدفت مركبه بالاسعاف ومنعه الصحفيين
من الاقتراب من المنطقه
الجيش الاسرائيلي مؤكدا انها نفذت من قبل
قوات خاصه تحت اطار ما يسميها عمليه كاسر
الامواج والتي بدات منذ اواخر مارس الماضي
وتتركز في مدن شماليه الضفه الغربيه التي
تحتلها اسرائيل منذ عام 67 نفذ خلالها
الجيش الاسرائيلي اكثر من 2000 عمليه
لاسيما في جنين ونابلس حيث يقول ان نشطاء
يخططون لهاجمات ضد اهداف اسرائيليه عمليات
تسببت بمقتل اكثر من 155 فلسطينيه وهي
الحصيله الاكبر منذ سبع سنوات حسب الامم
المتحده